Good morning everyone.
Welcome
and thank you all for joining us for this session today.
We're excited to tell you about how Manchester
Airport's Group,
or MAG,
are applying Agentic AI
so all of our flights can leave on time.
And quick show of hands, do we have any frequent flyers in
the room? Yeah,
lots of you.
Most of you probably use an airport to get here.
Then I'm sure you'll all agree.
This is the ideal scenario when flying.
You arrive at airport security.
An hour before your flight's due to take off.
And you sail straight through
with no delays.
We're all just looking to get through security
as quickly as possible
so we can start relaxing in the departure lounge
or getting down to some productive work.
Whether you're traveling for business
or for leisure.
However,
Whilst Mag have an outstanding record
of customer service in the airport.
Dealing with unexpected logistical challenges
is a daily occurrence.
And how frustrating is it for the passenger?
When your airport experience is not a smooth
one. And if flights are delayed
due to operational issues.
Now imagine you're the line manager
of the security line.
It's the week before Christmas. It seems like
the entire world is trying to travel
somewhere,
and all of a sudden
someone calls up,
it's one of your employees, and they won't be
able to make it in for their shift.
And all of a sudden you have the entire line to manage
and you also need to find a replacement for the single
employee that can't make it in.
How stressful.
My name's Tom Chester.
I'm a senior AI strategist at AWS
and I've been working with Mag over the past year
to help shape their AI vision.
I'm joined by my teammate Margarita
and Steve from MG.
And today,
we'll give you the context on the challenges
that MAG are facing
and outline the vision they saw
to apply AI to reduce
operational complexity.
We'll also cover why we have chosen Agenic
AI specifically
as a solution to this problem.
Finally, we'll take you through a technical deep dive
of how we helped Mag get started on this
journey by building the first use
case of many,
which focuses on the challenge
of rostering shift workers for
critical airport functions.
With over 1000 flights per day
leaving from Mags airports,
you can imagine the operational challenges
they have going on behind the scenes
to keep things running smoothly.
Many of you probably also work for companies with
complex internal processes.
Today, we'll share some of the practical lessons
that Mag learnt from applying Agentic AI
to these challenges,
with actionable insights
you can take forward to your own AI initiatives.
From a technical perspective,
the solution we've built uses Amazon Bedrock
Agent Core.
Which I'm sure lots of you will have heard about in the keynotes.
It's our primary service for deploying and operating
AI agents securely and at scale.
And as this is an L300 session, we'll be
getting into a lot of technical depth.
So Steve,
let's get started.
Great, thanks Tom.
So. Um
Why, why are you here? I guess, a big
thank you, um, for your time.
Uh, you'll have heard a lot already this week
about uh Agentic.
Um, and I'm gonna set,
uh, some of the context for,
uh, how we operate at the airport and then we'll dive into some
more of that technical detail later on.
Um, really excited to
share this part of the story with you guys. Um,
it's, it's not the beginning.
So, uh, this is actually a, a,
a hat trick. This is the 3rd time that MAG are presenting,
um, at, at Reinvent.
Um, we've also got solutions in
place, um, uh, Valve,
for example, uh, our, our, our AI
assistant supporting passengers.
And we're also, um, teaming AI
with computer vision
to determine how we can turn around aircraft
on, on, on the stand in a more efficient way.
Um, my role
is looking after our enterprise systems.
So that's the stuff that doesn't keep
the airplanes in the air but it's still equally as
important. Um, so finance, procurement,
HR, payroll,
workflow and automation,
um, and also the digital colleague workplace.
So a lot of this is going to be focused around
how we can improve our colleagues, um,
experiences,
um, rather than necessarily the, the passengers,
um, or, or our end customers.
So quick background into who our mag, so
UK based but global, um, presence.
We've got 3 airports, we're the largest
airport group in the UK.
And we also have uh an arm of the business
that's called Kavu that focuses on,
on travel tech and services. So
that our Kavu team are, are focused
on building a platform um to
to improve our passenger experience
um around
selling products like uh
lounge bookings, car parking,
um, and, and fast track through security.
Now we've got
some pretty ambitious, um,
uh.
Strategic aspirations,
um, and, uh, I guess
that's coupled with the fact that there's a significant
amount of operational complexity that we also have
to deal with across our, our airport base.
We've got around 9000 staff,
but many, many more, 40,000 or
so operating on our campuses,
um, across the airports in
the UK.
So Our aim is
to provide a seamless experience for our passengers,
um, an industry leading airport
experience.
Now Sounds
pretty simple,
but actually there's a a
an understandable amount of
of hard work and management of of complexity
that goes into
um achieving the KPI that you see
on screen there.
So
our aim is to provide a frictionless
yet secure journey for our passengers
through um security
and maintaining that level of service takes
a a a lot of monitoring I guess
of of all of the different components that that
come together.
Um and it doesn't always go smoothly.
Quick show of hands for anyone that
has flown in this week that their journey
wasn't quite as smooth through their airports.
As expected, OK.
Couple of hands.
Um. I actually
surprised myself. I, I got here so quick,
uh, I beat my luggage
by 2 hours.
That's interesting, isn't it?
The service that an airline and airport provide
means that me and my luggage arrived at
Harry Reid
2 hours apart. Hm.
So it it's things like that that
um.
The passengers just view as a hygiene
factor,
um, and
you know the particular use case that we're gonna come on to,
to, to dive into some technical detail around
is, is,
is just the first foray, I, I
guess there's, there's many other use cases that
we can apply this to.
So Cast
your mind back to the, to the example I just, I just
gave there around security, behind the scenes there's
there's lots of management of, of
operational complexity.
We've grown as an airport group um
over time.
COVID was also um uh.
A period of time that significantly impacted
us, um,
you know, only about 1 to 2% of
flights, um.
We're were going globally at that at that
time, mainly for mainly for cargo rather than
for passengers,
um, and it, it's meant
that there's, there's a significant amount of
complexity that we need to deal with in the airport.
And Also consider this,
there's a number of different parties and partners that
come together, so there's Mag staff,
there's also Border Force, there's our airline
partners, there's ground handlers.
All of these come together to deliver a service
that you as a passenger
may just, um,
consider as, as, as, you know, a, a, a, a,
a seamless
journey.
And the final point to mention is that passenger
safety and security is priority.
So, um, in order for us to prioritize
that, it often leads to higher operational costs.
So this was the opportunity for us.
Now This is the more exciting
bit that I really wanna talk to you about. Um,
and we are already
a, a good way along this journey.
Um,
and the, the opportunity for us
is, is huge.
So it's now Thursday morning,
um. AI
and Agentic is is not going to be a new
topic that you've heard about, um, at this point in
time throughout the week,
um, but we are going to go into a lot more
technical detail on how we've applied that.
Um, it's certainly no longer
a dream, it's, it's definitely a
reality,
um, and I hope that this customer story
and some of the lessons that we've learned along
the way is really useful.
Um, for you guys to, to consider,
to learn from,
um, and I'm really happy to take any questions as well at
the end of the session if you've got any, um,
thoughts or, or queries about how we apply that.
So our, our vision
is to create a single
unified experience for our colleagues
powered by agents.
Removing a significant amount of the complexity
in order to deliver value
for Mac,
and there's a host of different
use cases that we could apply this to,
um, the particular ones
that we've decided to, to focus on initially
are shown on the screen, but there are going to be many, many
more that we will
discover along the way.
Tom's gonna tell us a little bit more about um
how and why we've we've chosen
Agentic and then we'll go into the technical detail.
Now, perhaps some of the challenges
that Steve has shared are resonating with
you, and you're starting to think about
operational complexity
and technical debt in your own organizations.
Mag is certainly not alone in this regard.
It's something we hear time and time again from our customers
at AWS.
Whilst your company may not be coordinating
airport security
or delivering passengers' baggage,
every company has its own
operational processes.
But with a vision as bold as agentic AI
to control the airport.
Where do you start?
Many processes in the airport are high risk
and involve critical customer touchpoints.
And it's an environment where passenger safety and
security is non-negotiable.
So Mag had to get started on this journey
by finding the right use case.
And in doing so, we applied the framework
of think big,
start small,
and scale fast.
The digital colleague workplace is the think
big idea.
Agentic AI to control the airport.
But first, we had to securely lay the foundations
before iteratively adding functionality
and complexity.
It was also vital to find a use case
that not only demonstrates the power of agentic AI.
But also solves an immediate business problem
for Mag.
And demonstrates measurable value and
return on investment.
Well, Mag had identified exactly that kind
of opportunity,
which Steve will now share with you.
So
The first use case we selected was,
was around unplanned absence reporting.
So we're we're pretty good at forecasting and rostering
in the medium term,
but there's always these unplanned issues that
that that happen which means that you need to have
real time um
uh re-rostering of staff at any given
moment. Now, particularly
topical for us, it's a, it's a relevant um
and, and critical business need.
Um, but we needed to ensure that we
stayed laser focused on the outcomes here.
So yes, we're building a solution, but it needed
to ensure that we were reducing our operational
cost overall.
And that we were reducing our um
overtime payments, for example,
that we had to continue paying when other
um staff that were due to come onto
uh onto shift were unable to make it in at that time.
So significant cost drivers
that that underpinned why this was
a a particularly pertinent use case for
us to select.
Um, what does unplanned ill, uh, unplanned absence
consist of? Uh, primarily illness,
um, which is, uh,
of significant importance to us
around,
um, the summer peak,
around half-term periods where, where lots of
families go, go, go abroad,
um, and also coming up to Christmas.
Um,
of course there are other types of emergencies that also have
the same implication, right?
Travel, um,
issues with public transport or, or people's vehicles
enabling them to get in, or a family emergency
that people have to deal with.
So let's just take a look at the current
state. Um, there's probably two
key things
to, to, to mention in, in
this,
um. There's
the aspect of dealing with the re-rostering
of staff.
And so that's the, that's the top line of the thread.
And then secondarily, there's also
the pastoral care for that
employee that the line manager would need to take care of.
So in this instance, we would have
um an employee
calling in.
Uh, we've got a third party reporting helpline.
Um, the ros, the resourcing team would,
would deal with that. Uh, uh, re-rostering
would occur
and a replacement would be, would be scheduled.
In parallel,
the line manager would, would be informed,
um, and their HR record
on our, on our, um,
HR database would be, would be updated.
Um
Now that's all well and good for this
user group, but as you can imagine across 3 different
airports and different
um. Teams,
there is a very slightly different process in
place. Meaning
that we wanted to take the opportunity
to standardize,
but we had to ensure that the
outcomes being driven by the solution
that we built
were um were accurate
and er I guess
provided the the the same result
in very varying circumstances.
So
what's the, what's the value case behind it? I,
I touched earlier on some of
the reasons why we selected this as a use
case.
Um, but the value kind of stands
up for itself here. I'll talk you through the three
points in a second.
This is, this is only
for this particular use case.
Bearing in mind
this is step one on a larger journey for us.
So the, the value
case for an underlying digital colleague workplace
is even greater than this.
But the example here for unplanned absence
is really centered around reducing
the amount of cost on um
on payment of overtime to cover shifts.
The quicker we can get people through
security,
the greater level of spend that they typically have in
our terminals.
Um, and we also currently pay
an amount to a third party in order to
provide this service to us. So bringing it
in-house was, was something that was also
very, very, um, relevant.
Now, all sounds good doesn't it, but we
didn't just want to start charging ahead.
um there were some
very, very real, very pertinent considerations
that we needed to make.
Um
Alarm bells would probably be ringing across
organizations from cyber teams,
people teams perhaps,
security teams about how we're
going to ensure that we have the right
level of security,
um, accuracy of the solution
and reliability. So
you can imagine,
um. How are we authenticating
the user as they connect to submit their absence?
What if it's not them that's calling up because
they've been in an incident?
How, how do you secure and determine
who would call up on their behalf or or
use an use the app or web app front end
in order to submit that absence on their behalf?
Accuracy.
They're rostered for a shift,
but how much of a shift are they unable to attend?
Does that have an impact
on how we re-roster?
Does that have an impact on their end of
month take home pay cos they've worked less?
Reliability.
We operate a 24/7
operation across the airports.
This needs to be uh accessible,
it needs to be available.
It needs to have a low degree of of latency.
So A summary
of those impacts down the left that I've I've mentioned
are the considerations that we had to
um
that we, you know, that we had to discuss.
Ensure we had
suitable
um
solutions and and mitigations around
because at the, at the core, this is acting
over
PII data,
you know, it's impacting employees' pay.
And we're an airport group. We, we
operate over critical national infrastructure.
We are subject to an amount
of legislation, um,
to an amount of um.
To an amount of activity that is not uh
not equivalent for other organizations.
And so that was built into
some of the solution design,
uh, it informed how we structured our guardrails,
uh, it, it informed how we evaluated
how successful the the model and the solutions
were being,
and it also went into determining
um what our production architecture would
look like. So
Tom's gonna come and tell us a little bit more about why
Agentic is suitable here
and then we'll dive into the tech.
Great, thanks Steve.
So why do we think agentic AI is the
right fit for Mag's digital colleague workplace?
Let's first consider how generative AI
solutions evolve with increasing
autonomy in the context of Mag's use case.
At one end of the scale, we have generative AI
assistants, which can take the form of chatbots
or tools built for specific purposes,
such as document processing.
These can help to automate workflows,
but require humans to define and execute the
tasks.
Moving up the scale, AI agents have
much more autonomy.
They're given goals and focused on achieving
outcomes rather than just completing specific
tasks.
They're able to adapt dynamically under
uncertainty,
coordinating across multiple systems.
For Mag,
the unplanned absence reporting use case
would fall into this category.
Finally, at the other end of the spectrum,
we have fully autonomous agentic
systems.
These systems can not only accomplish the goals
that are given to them,
but can independently set and execute
on goals.
These systems are able to coordinate multiple agents.
With minimal human oversight.
Whilst quite rare today,
for Mag, this is the ultimate vision for the digital
colleague workplace.
Now let's take a look at the capabilities of agents
that are relevant to this use case.
Agents are given goals and instructions
and access to a set of tools to use
to help achieve these goals.
These could be in the form of a data source,
such as an employee data system.
Or
access to APIs for taking action in other
systems,
such as rostering an employee for a shift.
Agents are also given access to memory
so they can recall their short-term and long-term
interactions with the user for additional context.
Finally,
agents use their reasoning capabilities to
break down their goals into subtasks and
form a plan.
They take action using their tools to execute
that plan.
And observe the impact of those actions.
This observation may lead to more planning and
more action.
And so the loop continues until the
goal is achieved.
Equipped with these capabilities,
agents can also interact with other
AI agents.
Each with their own specialized set of goals and
tools.
This agent to agent interaction
allows for the creation of multi-agent systems,
which is Mag's ultimate vision for the digital
colleague workplace.
So returning to the question of why agentic
AI for Mag's digital colleague workplace.
Or to ask the question in a different way,
why wouldn't we have not just used a simple
automation tool or a generative AI
assistant for this use case?
The airport is a dynamic environment
with non-deterministic processes requiring
coordination
across many interdependent functions.
We've already talked about the complexity and the unplanned absence
reporting use case.
3 different airports,
many different process flows based on job type.
And numerous different types of absence,
each with their own
HR policy attached.
And quickly we're into hundreds of different workflow
permutations.
For example,
being absent due to childcare invokes
a different policy as opposed to illness.
And this is just one
of hundreds of processes
that Mag want to bring under the control of this system in
the long run.
For example, it'll also cover
fault reporting and asset management.
So what if a staffing decision in one part of the airport
is impacted by equipment being out of order in
another part of the airport?
And what if that's further compounded by a
large number of flights being delayed?
Agentic AI gives the ability to think through
these scenarios dynamically.
Whereas an automation tool would require
programming of hundreds of different workflow permutations
and still wouldn't capture all of the edge cases.
Agentic AI is also modular and extensible
by design.
Allowing Mag to iteratively add
functionality by deploying more agents
as they build towards the ultimate vision
of the digital colleague workplace.
We're laying the foundations for an intelligent
airport
where multiple different functions can interact
together to optimize operations.
The flexibility of agentic AI to handle
exceptions
where input received from the user is incomplete
or ambiguous,
is also key to making this work in the real
world. For example,
what if a user uses colloquial language
or misses key bits of information because they're
reporting in an emergency?
AI agents can use their inherent natural
language understanding
to engage in a multi-turn conversation with the user
until they have the information that they need.
Automation tools lack this inherent
understanding,
can only execute predefined paths,
and rarely handle exceptions gracefully.
Now, agentic AI is certainly not the right
fit for all use cases.
If you have a predictable, deterministic
workflow.
Then an automation tool may well be the way to go.
However, in Mag's case,
the combination
of complex non-deterministic processes.
The need for extensibility.
And high potential exception rates.
Made agentic AI the right choice.
So now that you know why we chose this approach,
let's see how we built the solution.
Thank you, Tom.
So you heard from Tom and Steve
why the type of problem that we're trying to tackle
here and why we chose
Agentic AI.
Now I'm gonna be telling you about exactly how
we went about building this solution.
I'll be talking about our development journey,
how we decided to build each component,
each component of our solution,
and also I'll be telling you about all the lessons
that we learned along the way that informed our
implementation patterns.
First, let's start with the current workflow.
What are we trying to solve here? OK,
so say you have an employee that comes,
uh, is unable to come to work. They have an unplanned
absence. Say they're ill.
The first thing that they do is
reach out to a point of contact.
This can be, uh, a line manager, a
rostering manager,
someone within the organization that can quickly rely to
whose full-time job is also something else. It's
managing other people and other workflows.
This point of contact needs to make sure they have
enough information about this employee to
know who they are and why they're reaching out.
They need to they need to know what the relevant HR
policies are for unplanned absences.
They also need to know what type of absence we're talking
about. A sickness absence
is not the same as a stuck in traffic absence.
Then they need to record this absence into an
HR system.
And notify all the relevant personnel, so
maybe another line manager or
something someone else.
And if this employee is a roasted employee, there's
additional steps you need to record the
absence into a shift record system
and you need to notify even more people.
So what I'm gonna be telling you about is how did we go from
this
current solution.
To our target solution.
And I know it looks complex, but don't worry,
we're going to build it little by little.
OK,
so the first thing, this is our solution.
This is, this is the current business workflow.
The first thing that we did looking
at this is how can we automate
each of these steps so that they can be done
by a software.
So for example, we can connect to an API,
uh, we can connect to an HR rostering
system
with an API call.
We can look at HR policies with a
knowledge base,
we can classify absences through
an LLM,
and we can notify a manager through Amazon SNS,
our messaging
solution. Now,
let me simplify this a tiny bit.
OK. So
we started testing this
and you know instead of having a point of
contact you can have a deterministic workflow because these are
all just tools.
But
this doesn't quite always work. So if an
employee comes in and gives incomplete
information. Then our tool
doesn't work already
because it can't quite record the full absence.
This is why we really need an agentic
workflow here.
We need a natural conversational pattern that
is able to collect all the relevant
information from the employee.
Now we can connect this agent to all of these tools,
quite. Pretty much the
same way as they were done deterministically before
and give it a prompt that will tell us exactly what it's
meant to do.
And
I know you guys have heard about agents before,
but Let's make sure
we're all on the same page here. Agents go with
the react pattern
where, given a human input,
they would.
Reason? Act
Observe
And give you a response.
So here our agent is implemented with strands,
and each reasoning step is logged
in an S3 bucket for observability.
And what do our tools look like?
So our tools are
like this one, for example, which extracts all
the information from the user that
the agent needs to take the further
steps. OK,
so we have our first agent.
And we were excited.
It worked in our demo.
And then we started testing it.
And we got some unwanted
behavior. We looked
into it and we came to our first
big learning.
You need to adapt your tools for agents.
You will all have tools in your current work
streams that are like software tools
that already give you the right answers that an agent
can use,
but agents can be so much
more accurate and fast
if you give them,
if you manage to tweak your tools a tiny bit.
So engineer Verbose error catching.
Tools like humans
need to know why an error is appearing, otherwise
they're not able to find an alternative path to your
solution. Make
the tool's output human readable.
Sure, LLMs can like
understand all J's and formats,
but just like us they're gonna be quite a lot faster if you tell
them the information that they need to look in
these outputs.
So if you already know what information exactly you're gonna have
to extract from it,
just do that extra step for them if you can.
Then combine sequential tools. This is really
important for latency.
If you have a sequence of tools that you know that are
always going to be called in the same sequence, just
do them together.
So in our example about extracting
employee information,
this is the type of output that we want
to achieve
as opposed to this really.
So lesson number one,
adapt your tools for agents.
OK, So we have
our text to text solution.
Text to text solution we have our first solution
which is reachable by text
and
it worked
on my laptop. It was great,
but of course not all the employees are gonna come to my
laptop and play with it. We need scale.
What if 50 employees need to use it at the same
time? And
of course you can start, you can start going
down the realm of
hosttigen on a lambda, and then you need to think about a
wet socket state management.
These were like weeks of work to make sure that
everything would work correctly, how you intended it to
work. But then
We actually have a really good solution for this that
encaptures all of that complexity,
and that's
Agent Corey Vheim.
OK. So Adrian Cora on
time solved this in one afternoon.
I know you heard about Agent Core
quite a bit throughout these 5 days,
but just to give you a quick overview
if you
haven't.
Agent Core
uh gives you the skill and security to deploy
your agents securely.
And right now I'm talking about Agent Corre
runtime where you can host your agents.
It comes in a wider ecosystem of
tools that Agent Corre
has built.
And a wider set of capabilities
that are actually even wider than what I have on the
screen right now.
But the main reasons why I like Agent Core
runtime is because it's compatible with
all open source infrastructure
such as NTP servers and various
frameworks where you can host your agents.
So we are using runtime here with trans agents,
and I'll be talking about the model context
protocol that we built with it.
OK, and now so we have one employee coming
in. A 2nd,
a 3rd, and a 5th
agent core runtime solves our issue by
being a server-less solution
that connects directly with the front end
and has state persistency
so that each one of these employees
gets an answer.
So we have a solution
that handles conversations with runtime.
And now we started thinking about the future.
What happens if we expand the scope of
this agent?
What happens if in the future we want
an employee that reports something different apart from an absence?
For example,
a
broken escalator.
Now we have an issue because our
current solution cannot handle this.
So we can either take the solution apart
and tweak it and we put it out,
but this is a monolithic
approach to this problem. You'd need to make sure
that everything is working all over again.
What if you can separate concerns? What if you can
separate the concern of all of your tools
from the concern of your agent?
This is why we decided to
host our tools on an MCP server.
An MCP server gives you a standard way of
exposing the tools, which means that not only
I can change the tools, but I can also then reuse
these tools in a new set of circumstances
with a different agent if I want to.
And these tools are now hosted in Agent
Core Gateway.
Agent Core Gateway makes sure that
the agent
can discover all of these tools automatically.
How does it work?
An employee comes in with a question to Agent Core
on time or the agent hosting on Agent Core on
Time. Agent Coreravo Time connects
to Agent Core Gateway and searches for the correct
tool to answer that question.
It then is able to query that tool,
get the results.
And answer the
user's question.
Crucially,
we can add more tools on the fly.
And all of this is through a single API call
to Agent Corey Gateway.
So our working text-based solution
was working beautifully.
In testing.
And we took the leap
and we went through our security review
and our security reviewer looked at us and was like,
OK.
What stops someone from social engineering
the agent into doing something malicious?
We're like, yeah, that's a great question.
Well, of course,
We would add, we would add guard rails.
So we started adding guard rails and it
worked really well.
For extreme solutions.
But what if a user is
a bit sneakier or if they're trying
to engineer a conversation over multiple
steps.
And keep in mind here we're talking about an airport.
If an absence is misrecorded, this
means issues with like checkpoints, flight
systems. This has like high
impact. So
this.
Of course,
without the proper security this would go
through. And
it led us to our second lesson.
You have to think broader than standard guardrails.
Write custom guardrails for compliant and
responsible AI.
Current Pedro guardrails only look at
the last message that the
uh person has written.
When you think about guard railing, of course the first
thing that you should always think about is the
principle of least privilege.
Make sure that whatever tool the agent is
using. Can only be used
by the person that is authenticated,
but sometimes you kind of just need to leave a bit of flexibility
to an agent to use multiple tools.
In this case, you really want to define unwanted
conversation patterns.
And build guard rails that have a context
of the conversation so that they can actually track that
conversation pattern and react in case
the pattern is deviating from a stand-up
pattern that you want your agent to interact with.
So in,
in our scenario,
we added a context aware guard rail
through a um lambda,
and this is based on recovering the
memory of the agents and
having an LLM as a guard
rail. Now,
we have a microservice-based agent
with Guardro. But
we still have one crucial component
missing. What
if Macy, who is in her car, she's
driving to work, she's sitting in traffic,
and she can't quite make it in time for her shift?
What happens then?
In her previous solution, she would have like picked up her
phone, she would have called her manager, she would have been, I'm
sorry, I'm late,
and this would have all been solved for her.
Now she would really have to take off, take out
her phone, open an app,
write some texts,
all things that you really cannot do in a car.
Hence we need a speech to speech solution.
Here we built our speech to speech solution
thanks to Amazon Novasonic.
If you're not familiar with Amazon Novasonic, it's
a speech to speech model that is able to
interact with you
verbally.
Now speech to speech adds a
real-time streaming complexity.
So
Novasonic expects continuous audio
input and gives out continuous audio
output.
And so this can't really go through a
request response pattern like our text to text
model. So we have to
handle this with a web socket
connection, and this is managed by
the ECS.
Which buffers the audio frames
and coordinates the bidirectional stream.
Great, so now we have the infrastructure
to make sure that the user can speak
to Novasonic.
But now Novasonic is a model, we
need to prompt it. And so we're like, great, we're gonna
use the same prompt that we use for the text model and we're
gonna go to Novasonic and it's gonna work.
Let us do our next lesson.
Read speech to speech model prompts out
loud. Speech to
speech models have actually been trained
on speech and so
they they can't think as complexly.
As a text to text model.
Don't rely on chain of thought,
no human will actually tell you what
it's thinking about before actually saying it.
Write out enumeration patterns. These
are great on a text prompt to give an
idea to the model of what you're about to do,
but no one enumerates their sentences when they
speak. And
think about spelling.
Your model just like you might not know all
the names of all the different nationalities that are
around you, so help the model think about
how to deal with these edge cases
and situations.
So read your speech to speech to speech model
prompts out loud.
So we did this, we redrafted our prompt
to be more speech-based as opposed
to text-based.
And then
we had our model that connected to our user
for now for a front end but in the future
through a phone line
and now this model needs to connect
with all the tools that we built for the text to text
model, which led to
a bit of a concern because as we just said, you
want a speech to speech model to interact
with uh a verbose
answer like something that you can read out loud
and all of these tools.
Are mainly like software outputs. Yes,
we've improved them a tiny bit with lesson number one, but
they're still mainly like
systems.
But then we had an aha moment.
There's a part of this infrastructure
that is already trained to give you a
human readable response, and that's your
text to text model. That's the agent, the
text agent that we built as the initial
solution, the written solution.
So instead of connecting Amazon Novasonic
directly to the tools,
we connected Amazon
Novasonic
to the text agent
that we had already built.
Like this, we have an agentic hierarchy
where Novasonic calls as
a tool the text tool,
the text model that then calls all the tools.
And this also solves other problems that we
would have encountered.
Instead of having two sources of truths about
how to use these tools and how to think about these problems
in the text and in the speech to speech models,
now we can just keep it in the text to text model
and leave the speech model to just know when it
has to call that tool.
And
this is great, but we still have a cru crucial
concern, which is if you're calling
the model,
then you're not authenticated.
If you're
using a text to text model through an app, you're usually
authenticating before you get exposed to that model.
But here we had an authentication problem.
So we built an authentication tool.
We asked Navasonic to collect all
the relet, all the relevant information from
the user.
And then pass it to an authentication tool
that would compare this information to
the information stored in the HR system
and return an answer on whether or not that
user gave the right information and could be authenticated,
after which Novasonic was allowed to use the
text to text tool.
So,
think about your authentication with speech to speech models.
OK, so here it is.
This is the full architecture, our gentic
AI solution from unplanned absence reports.
So we got here and we demoed this to
our business stakeholders.
So we showed them the architecture,
we showed them a demo
where a person would come in and be like they're sick,
they can't come in.
And as expected, our agents started
by authenticating the user,
categorizing the absence.
Recording absence with the HR system.
Notifying the managers,
and all this while the employee was getting no response.
And it got to this point and our business stakeholder was like,
oh, is it frozen?
Lesson number 4, and perhaps the most crucial
lesson.
You can have the most amazing backend
that can do all the most amazing tasks,
but agentic still requires an agent
to go through a set number of tools which
actually will always take some latency,
which will always feel too much for an end user,
and UI is king.
You need to keep your user engaged.
So you need to add intuition on
what the agents are doing behind
the scenes.
Well keeping this high level enough so that you're not
revealing all your infrastructure in the
back end.
UI is king.
So what does, what does this look like?
Let me show you this in action.
So this is our UI.
We have a person coming in so that they can't come into
work, and they give you a good reason why.
And
the agent starts processing this
information, retrieving all the user
information. Then classifying
the type of absence that this user is coming
with and then realizing it doesn't
quite have enough information to fully
record the absence.
So it asks for more information
that the user then provides.
And then the agent is back to work.
Figuring out what day it is, when is the person
coming back in the calendar,
and then creating all the records
of absences.
In this case, the user is a rostered
user, so we need to record both the absence
into an HR system
and the rostering system and notify
both their manager and their rostering
manager. And then also
making sure that the user is aware of
what has been done behind the scenes,
so it also sends a message to
the user
about.
All the tasks that have been done.
So this is it, our solution.
So our key takeaways
are 4.
The first is adapt
your tools for agents.
Make sure you use verbose error catching.
And minimize consecutive tool
calls by merging them.
Second
is ride guard rails for multi-turn
conversations.
Make sure that your agent cannot be strayed away from
its intended use.
The 3rd is read your speech to speech
model prompts out loud.
And the 4th is UI is king.
Keep your user engaged.
So how did this work for us?
But we've managed to standardize the way the absences
are recorded in the system,
and we now have a 99% consistency in
absence reporting.
This is unleashing a lot of potential into analyzing
what the patterns in the absences are downstream.
And we also reduce the time it takes for recording
these absences by 90%.
But I'm going to let Steve tell you more about what's
the what's in stock with Mag for
the future. Thanks,
Margarita.
So. That's
just a small window into I I guess
what we've achieved this time round.
Um, we are well on our
way to becoming uh or achieving
our strategy which is
um to become the world's most intelligent airport group.
You can obviously see what some of the next steps are, right,
so why not automated rostering?
Um, think about the operational size of the airport, spinning
up certain bits of the terminal depending on
which, um, stands are going to be used
or or not when they're out of use.
Um, there is a whole stack of of
more use cases that we intend to apply this
to. Um,
it, it will ultimately uh result
in us having more agents with the
right level of humans in the loop.
A great number more tools that we're leveraging
and ultimately a more autonomous, efficient
and effective er airport.
Great, thanks Steve.
Margarita and I are part of a team at AWS
called the Generative AI Innovation Center.
The QR code on screen will take you to our homepage.
We're a build a team that support AWS customers
in building generative AI solutions to their
problems. If
what you've heard today resonates with you
and you'd like to discuss building Agentic AI with us,
please do get in touch via your AWS
account manager.
And now, as we bring this presentation into
land,
I'd like to thank you all very much for your time
today. Please do remember
to complete the survey in the mobile app,
and if you have any questions,
we'll be available afterwards, but outside the theater.
Thank you. Thank you.